just Justin gaiety versus Alex
wilkinowski make sense if Justin doesn't
want to wait now Justin is down to eight
Justin likes a lot of layoff between his
fights he's not a guy that rushes into
things he's actually more about taking
longer rests having a full Camp so I'm
assuming he's down to weight but outside
of a title shot which I think they're
going to give him but let's say they
don't you know the Darius fight doesn't
make sense coming off a loss Justin
gaichi wants to fight for a title that
doesn't even closer to the title
folkanovski just it's a big fight big
fight volkenazi stock is higher than
ever after we did the yair there's not a
lot at 45 for volcanovski anymore if he
does want to you know kind of play with
55 Makita fight just happened so it
doesn't make a ton of sense but I would
watch it does he want to fight a guy
like just engage you I think he matches
up really well Justin gaichi I think
it's a pay-per-view Main Event if Justin
gaichi for whatever reason UFC doesn't
offer him that title shot right away if
I'm just engagedy I'd rather take a big
name fight and vocal knots get 55